President Biden and Democrats about to
throw more gasoline on their inflation
dumpster fire after jamming through the
Senate there are 740 billion dollar
inflation reduction act the massive bill
will unleash an avalanche of your
taxpayer money on liberal wish list
items like climate change it will also
jack up taxes during a recession and
while Democrats are riding high now
Republicans say they'll pay the price in
the midterms the President Biden thinks
is a major win listen
do I expect you to help yes I do it's
going to need you to help for example
so senior
will have any on Medicare we'll have a
bill for more than two thousand dollars
for drugs no matter what the costs are
that's a big deal change people's lives
there's a whole range of things that are
really game changed as an ordinary folks
now some of it's not going to kick in
for a little bit but it's all good it's
really going to lower the daily when you
sit down that kitchen table the end of
the month
and if you love getting audited listen
up Democrats will be sending an army of
IRS goons after your bank account after
giving them 80 billion dollars to ramp
up enforcement and hiring 87 000 new IRS
agents and get this the agency will end
up with more staffers than the state
department FBI and border patrol
combined
the Democrats think they're pretty
clever by calling the bill the inflation
reduction act but even Senator Bernie
Sanders can see through that charade
I want to take a moment to say a few
words
about the so-called inflation reduction
act that we are debating
uh this evening
and I say so-called by the way because
according to the CBO
and other economic organizations go
study this bill it will in fact have a
minimal impact on inflation all right
Senator sand uh Senator Scott excuse me
you're not Bernie Sanders praise the
Lord
uh you were there when the sausage was
being made what is the most worrisome
thing about this bill well I think what
you said to start the show was really
important it's not just those three
departments it also includes the
Pentagon so if you had all four of those
departments together you're still going
to have a bigger IRS and the most
scariest the scariest part for our
viewers
87 000 new employees hunting for taxes
from people making less than two hundred
thousand dollars that's a lot of us it's
not the billionaires and the
millionaires it's literally middle
income families low-income families and
entrepreneurs who are trying to figure
out how to keep their employees working
and invest in their future when they
name this thing the inflation reduction
act were you guys on the Republican side
just kind of snickering about that well
I call it the inflation seduction act oh
yeah it literally it has nothing to do
with reducing inflation when Bernie
Sanders and Tim Scott and Ted Cruz are
all on the same side that tells you that
whatever they're selling we're not
buying Greg Gutfeld your reaction to
what happened over the weekend well it's
funny it's like whenever a con man has
aliases that's that's a tip off this
bill has changed its name more times
than Kanye West right you know it was a
it was inflation then it was climate
then it was Health Care there was tax
policy did I say climate this says more
faces than Nancy Pelosi but they do this
so they can keep you off the set so they
can overwhelm you I don't believe this
bill passed it just wore every everyone
down we even get we even have a hard
time following this stuff spending bills
are now like cell phone plans so they
padded with so many options and
directions and false flags that you
can't possibly follow all of it so you
can't compete like you can't figure out
what's the better cell phone plan you
can't figure out if this plan is good or
if it's bad are you a lawyer Senator I'm
not thank God thank God I would say we
need more mechanics we need more
plumbers in politics less attorneys
because the attorneys take the simplest
thing and then they layer it with
complexity so it keeps their sides busy
the fact that they're adding all these
IRS agents shows you that this is a
feedback loop right it's how they pay
for their fantasies so one half of the
bill is the fantasies right the things
they want to spend on and everything the
other half has to steal to pay for it so
it's like a never-ending system it's a
configuration that could go on forever
anytime you want to put more money in
you just hire more IRS agents and then
you go well see it's going to be paid
for because we got the these guys over
here it's a feedback loop that can't end
it's really strange Americans do not
need a doubling of the IRS crime is
Raging out of control control but it's
easier to go after White Collar
criminals than people who will shoot
back at you so you go after the guy who
pays his you know waitresses and bus
boys under the table those are the
people that we want to put away and
they're not going to want to hassle with
it so instead they're just going to say
the money to afford uh lawyer fees I'll
just pay what I pay that's how they get
you is this the future of legislation
you just basically get every single
thing that your party wants put it into
a big Kettle and then rename it
something like the American Dream Act or
something like that this is what we're
used to I mean everything is not as it
seems like this whole Administration is
all about don't believe Your Lying Eyes
just because it makes sense to you
doesn't mean it's true and you know they
call it the inflation reduction act I
think they should call it the election
uh seduction act because what they're
doing is they're trying to convince
America that this is going to help you
with inflation you know you have to read
the fine print to know it's not going to
have any impact on inflation and it's
going to be better for you just like Joe
the president said you're going to have
a whole lot more money to pay your bills
hogwash you're going to have a whole lot
more money gas is still the same chicken
is still the same the prices of
everything are still the same and what
is it 0.1 percent of one percent or
whatever it is that the CBC uh yeah
whatever the Congressional budget
see
oh oh you can say whatever you want okay
thank you now why say the truth that's
why I paused and took it from my
Democrat friend here here's the thing
they want to sick the IRS on the
American people and Senator I didn't
realize that the primary uh people that
they're going after are people making
less than two hundred thousand dollars
that sickens me ninety percent of their
revenue comes from people under two
hundred thousand dollars is their
projection and that is sickening because
if they dealt with crime as Greg said
and instead put 87 000 more cops on the
street at least so they could say look
we didn't mean it when we said deep on
the police we were only kidding and just
to prove it we're going to put 87 000
more cops on the streets no they're
looking to make us criminals and that's
that's a shame it's a bad situation
they're going to hammer small businesses
and we're going to suffer so they say
the American people care about crime the
economy inflation the border and
climates right down here down near the
bottom but this whole thing is stuffed
with climate stuff so how can the
Democrats say this is a win Harold first
good to be back with you Senator welcome
a couple things
um I have a slightly different view on
this um
Mansion we're all going to do three
things Senator manchin your colleague
Senator Scott and Larry Summers two big
Democrats have long been opposed to the
bill back better act they thought it was
too expensive they thought inflation uh
and Senator match have taken has already
thought inflation was the driving force
so he was an author of this bill so
either he's a liar
he's fibbing a little bit or he has been
he's been a swage of his concerns that
inflation I look at people in the most
favorable light I think he's been a
swage of those concerns Larry Summers
was a huge critic huge critic of
spending even back during the covet era
the big 1.9 trillion dollar spending
Bill he has decided that this bill is it
satisfies many of his concerns meaning
meaning when it's not going to have a a
upward pressure impact on inflation now
even the the people that Bernie Sanders
now I have to tell you if Bernie Sanders
is on one side of something saying it's
not enough money being spent
and someone else is on the side saying
there's too much money being spent I'm a
moderate Democrat that's kind of where I
want to be and I think perhaps if they
turn out to be wrong here I love that
ringer they turn out to be wrong then we
should all admit that they're wrong but
this bill does four things it lowers the
debt 300 billion dollars that's why they
think it's going to fight inflation it
lowers drug costs one of the one of the
key drivers in households all across
this country in South Carolina Tennessee
New York and elsewhere or the cost that
people have to pay for drugs my son had
had a prescription this weekend thank
God I was able to afford it it was a a
number that was probably outside of the
range for someone else but thank God I
was able to afford it that's what this
is trying to do and two it increases
domestic energy production it does a lot
on on climate change but it also there's
no way Joe manchin would not want more
coal not want more fracking and not want
more drilling right yeah there's no
nuclear there is nuclear in it there's
room for nuclear in it as well so now
one thing I think press one of the
things I wish the Press would have done
was give us a little more analysis
around this but it's not perhaps not
enough uh and finally it increases taxes
when it increases taxes on the
wealthiest Americans and because and it
pays for it pays for what it does that
we can disagree with that what are they
something the taxes still well they have
to pay for some of this no but what do
you say they're raising taxes what are
we going to have to pay now well you may
be in that category
the vast majority and I look I'm invited
to his house
the point is this chips this
infrastructure Bill killing Al Qaeda now
you got to do a crime and Border
Democrats you're on a roll don't don't
let up yeah you know they're on a roll
and we're the meat in that sandwich
Harold I'm gonna Crush you right now
this week's heard this whole same thing
in 2009 with that whatever clean energy
bill what did we get we got solyndra and
we got remember the beautiful billion
dollar light rail system system so what
do they have in California now rolling
blackouts thank you for that bill so you
know what Harold how does it feel to be
utterly humiliated on National
Television if I turn out to be wrong
I'll come right back on the ceremony and
if this bill works I want the same from
you you'll never get it from me yeah
we'll be determining whether it works or
not I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the this is the way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now